I'm back, baby. I'm back.
Fuck this fucking light it's too hot in here
Okay, I'm ready..
I mean, I'm ready for the first time
Welcome, I'm gonna play "the hardest level in the world"
"oh it's so difficult"
shut up
SHUT YOUR MOUTH
where is it, this piece of shit level, where is it?
WHERE IS IT
Give me that Stormy Ascent
apparently they deleted this level off the game because it was too hard
"BOOHOO!
the game is too hard delete this level. It's too hard for me!"
BLAH
Nonsense!
no level is too hard
I've never died a single time and this is my first time EVER playing this level
so let's see how it goes, okay, shall we?
I got new energy
uhh from--
Nothing, okay? This is the first-- zero deaths by the way
in case you're new to my channel. I am a---
fuck
I am a pro gamer, not a fuck. [yes you are]
look at my into-ish---
fuuck you
[swedish swear]
there it is, easy
as squeezing a tit-sy
That totally rhymed. Thank you.
I could beat this level blindfolded
playing with my butt cheeks
that's how easy this is
actually I'm doing it right now
come on
Zero deaths, come on
come on baby
first checkpoint
don't need it, but I'll take it just to to make you guys happy
zero deaths
ooooOOOOHH
You thought I was gonna die, BITCH
ZERO
MOTHA
FLIPPIN
DAATHS
BAATCH
fuck you, molesting man
easy
Look at this jump, easy!
YEAH, second checkpoint
asa bajania[?]
EASY, I kill myself on PURPOSE!
AAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHH
Zero deaths, everyone, that was a glitch in the matrix
something happened, I don't know what
GET UP ON IT , YOU FUCKING BITCH
Can you not?
*sigh*
Here we-- here we goes again
zero deaths
zero
fucking
deaths
another checkpoint, thank you
Don't need them 'cause I never die, ever
Fuck, I fucked up now
this part is impossible
WHAAAT?
LOOK AT THAT SHIT, bOOi
hOOOOOh
NEIGHHHH [more like NEEEIN]
fuck
How did I do it now, Jesus
skills
Fuck Jesus [please don't]
oh my god
When do I jump then??
you schmuck
I want to beat this fucking level so hard
When do I fucking jump you fucking piece of piss fist[?]
Game. Over.
hate this fucking level
Hey, everyone, welcome! Ma nama Jeff
Welcome, I'm a pro gamer
Gamer s--five, everyone
I'm gonna play this game, thank you
never die before
5 mil on death in 6 months---
fuck you, I'm not gonna make that jump
Look at that shit boy
I fly through this level, like a fly flying through the sun and burns itself to death.
Thank you [you're welcome for whatever I've done]
jesus
first checkpoint, dab on them
What the f--shit cake
sTOP
thank you
JEEZUZ
SECOND CHECKPOOIINT
DAB on thEEEMM
o my lord
oh my, fist me daddy
Yes, come on. Come on. Come on. YES
FUCK, a dUUUk
ddUUUHH
FIRST CHECKPOINT
DAAB ON 'EM haters
*exhale*
It's too bad this part is virtually fucking impossible
without getting hurt
See, it's fucking impossible.
I don't even know why I fucking tried
oouugggh
🎵In the end, it doesn't even matter🎵
Fuck yeah, that's it, easiest jumps.
Come on. Come on. Come on man
I need these I need these lives otherwise. I'm dead [zero deaths tho]
This jump is tricky
Fuck, okay. Well great. I'm dead. I'm dead now. I'm dead now.
Are you happy? Are you happy? Are you happy? Are you fucking happy?
[oh shit what's gonna happen]
YEES
FUCK OFF
Come on
I have so many fucking lives. Not that I fucking need it
cuz zero FUcking deaths
Come on
what the--?
Oh, Jesus
what happened?
da fuk? what happened??
Now I definitely don't have one [ONe WHAT? i have not been paying attention to this video at all]
ohhh
*big sigh*
Oh my God
Yes
This fucking jump sucks so much dick
Yeah, that will do the trick
FUCK
OOOI I hate that jump
I get it now
I fucking get it now
I fucking get it
OOOOh, I want to do it so bad
FUUCK You
come on you piss boy
oh my god, you're so
STUPID!!! [ANGERY]
*gasp* OOOOOHHHH
YEEESSSSS
ZERO FUCKING Death
AWWWEEEE
ahhhhh  ha
*creepy laugh*
FUCK YOU GAME, just like Dark Souls
Just
Like
Dark
Souls
Fuck you. I respect woman and only fucking shit [?!!]
hell yeah
life for bitches
fuck you
god fucking damn it [pewds don't give up!]